foreign
decade I owned and operated a restaurant
called 11 Madison Park
to give you some context if you don't
know what that is 11 Madison is a very
fancy restaurant on the corner of 24th
and Madison here in New York City I mean
like very fancy we're talking servers
wearing suits and ties like crisp ironed
white tablecloths more than 30 Cooks in
the kitchen serving like 10 15 course
tasting menus I think you get the gist
when I got there in 2006 it was kind of
a middling Brasserie but by the time I
sold it at the beginning of 2020 it had
been named the number one restaurant in
the world
[Applause]
now to be clear our kitchens served
unbelievably delicious and Incredibly
Innovative food our service was so
gracious and as close to technically
perfect as possible in our dining room I
mean just Google a picture it's one of
the most beautiful out there
and it was because of those reasons that
we are consistently on the list of the
50 best restaurants in the world
but it was a hot dog that earned us the
number one spot on that list
or rather the winning strategy that it
gave birth to
unreasonable hospitality
the principle that guided us as we took
ordinary transactions and turned them
into extraordinary experiences
in early 2010 on a busier than normal
lunch service I was in the dining room
helping out the servers when I found
myself clearing appetizers from a table
of four Foodies on vacation to New York
and they were going to the airport to
head back home after their meal
I ever heard them talking what an
amazing trip we've been to all the best
restaurants and they listed a bunch uh
per se laburnaden Danielle and Momofuku
now 11 Madison Park
then another person jumped in yeah but
the only thing we didn't get to try was
a New York City hot dog
you know those moments in a cartoon
where the animated light bulb goes off
over the character's head signifying
they're about to come up with a really
good idea
if you'd been in the room with me that
day you would have seen what appear of
her mind
as calmly as I possibly could I walked
gracefully back into the kitchen dropped
off the plates and then literally ran
out the front door and down the block to
the hot dog cart I bought a hot dog and
ran just as fast back into the kitchen
now came the hard part
convincing the chef to serve it and our
fancy fine dining restaurant
because he looked at me like I'd lost my
mind
serving what New Yorkers call a dirty
water dog in a fancy four-star
restaurant but I asked him to trust me
and I told him it was important to me
and eventually he agreed to cut the hot
dog up into four perfect pieces adding a
little swoosh of ketchup and a swoosh of
mustard on Peach plate and finishing
them with a canal of sauerkraut and a
canal of relish
then before we serve to the table their
final Savory course which happened to be
a honey lavender glazed Muscovy duck
that had been dry aged for two weeks
utilizing a technique that had taken
years to perfect
we brought them their hot dog
I introduced it
to make sure you don't go home with any
culinary regrets
a New York City hot dog
guys
they freaked out
I'm not kidding at that point in my
career I had served thousands of dishes
and many many many thousands of dollars
worth of food and I can confidently say
that no one had ever reacted to anything
I served them better than they reacted
to that hot dog
each person said it was not only the
highlight of their meal but if their
entire trip to New York and they'd be
telling the story for the rest of their
lives
see that hot dog changed the way I
approach restaurants from that point
forward because up until then I had been
so focused on Excellence on all the
little details that go into making a
meal great that I somehow hadn't
realized something really important
that in restaurants our reason for being
is to make people feel seen
it's to make them feel welcome
it's to give them a sense of belonging
see in restaurants the food the service
the design they're simply ingredients
in the recipe of human connection
that is hospitality
and I realized if we could be
unreasonable in our pursuit of that
we could give people the kind of
experiences they would remember forever
it was only then that I realized I
wasn't actually in the business of
serving people dinner
I was in the business of serving the
memories
I obsessed over that hot dog I kept on
going back to the experience and trying
to figure out what happened that you
know the whole thing went down like what
happens that it could happen and what
needed to happen is that it could start
happening all the time
first
being present
which I get it's like kind of overused
these days but for me being present
Means Caring so much about the thing
you're doing or the person you're with
that you stop caring about all the other
things you need to do
and it's essential in delivering
unreasonable hospitality
see so often we have such long to-do
lists that we aren't able to slow down
enough to actually listen to the people
around us
to the things they're saying and all the
things they're not saying
if I hadn't been present to that table I
never would have heard that throwaway
line about the hot dog
second
it required taking what you do seriously
without taking yourself too seriously
way too often in customer service
businesses we let these self-imposed
standards get in the way of us giving
our customers the thing they actually
want
okay a hot dog in a four-star restaurant
is sacrilegious
but look at the way it made them feel
and third it required the acknowledgment
that if what you're trying to do is give
people a sense of genuine belonging
one size fits one
hospitality is about making people feel
seen
and the best way to do that is not to
treat them like a commodity
but as a unique individual
I really do believe I could have comped
that table a bottle of vintage champagne
and given them a free bucket of caviar
and it would not have had the same
impact as that two dollar hot dog
because it would not have been specific
to them
the hot dog had given us a new true
north
and now we had a road map
I started talking about it constantly at
staff meetings telling the team like
what led to the gesture and encouraging
them to go out into the dining room to
find Opportunities of Their Own
and they were just as fired up as I was
and we got started right away every
night finding a few really cool
experiences to deliver to our guests
we had unlocked something important we
knew it was working
but we wanted more of it we wanted to
give these kinds of things to almost
everyone we wanted to make it a bigger
part of our our culture
and we recognized that we needed to
invest in the resources to make that
possible
so
we added a position to the team
someone whose only responsibility was to
help everyone else bring their ideas to
life
we called the position the Dreamweaver
named after the iconic song by Gary
Wright
you've heard it even if you don't think
you have
I'll help you it goes something like
Whoa Dream Weaver
I'm sorry I
I just had to sing it because that song
is actually pretty important to me it
was playing the first time I kissed a
girl it will now be stuck in your head
for the rest of the day you're welcome
and with the addition of that position
we were on fire
sincerely a guest warned us in advance
that his dad was more of a Budweiser
steak and potatoes kind of guy than
sawturn and foie gras so the
dreamweavers turned our fancy champagne
cart into a Budweiser cart filled with
every available type of Budweiser at
every Bodega in the neighborhood
a couple came in to console themselves
after their Beach vacation flight was
canceled
so at the end of their meal we turned
our private dining room into their very
own private beach with reclining folding
chairs a ton of sand on the ground and a
kiddie pool filled with water they could
dip their feet into while they drowned
their sorrows over tropical Mai ties
with those little umbrellas
or a family of four from Spain was in
the restaurant they were in New York on
vacation and while they were eating the
most beautiful thing happened
the kids were looking at our massive
windows with Wonder
it had started snowing and it was the
first time they'd ever seen real snow
the Dreamweaver somehow found a store
that was still open at eight o'clock on
a Friday night when they left the
restaurant there was a chauffeur-driven
SUV waiting to take them to Central Park
for the most special nightcap a few
hours of play in the freshly fallen snow
with these gestures and so many more our
guests were obviously happier than ever
but you know what this is the cool part
so is our team
because for the first time they had
creative autonomy they were no longer
just helping to execute someone else's
Vision serving plates of food someone
else had created they were coming up
with their own ideas and those ideas
were affecting the guest experience
they were empowered
but mostly
I mean we were all just happy because we
were making other people really really
happy
there are a few things more energizing
than seeing the look of complete Joy on
someone's face when they receive a gift
that you are responsible for giving
it can become one of the most beautiful
addictions
and as we all found ourselves quickly
becoming addicted to going above and
beyond for our guests we found ourselves
going above and beyond for one another
as well
now I'm just going to say this because
I'm sure some people are thinking it
unreasonable hospitality is not just for
fancy restaurants
I get it some of the gestures I just
described were quite extravagant we did
hire people under the team to help us
execute them more consistently
but remember that hot dog only cost two
dollars and the impact it had was
priceless
it does not take a big budget to start
infusing this into your culture because
remember it's not the cost of the
gesture that matters it's how it makes
people feel
for most of America's history we were a
manufacturing economy now we're a
service economy and dramatically so more
than three quarters of our GDP is driven
by service Industries globally it's more
than 65 percent
that means that whether you're in real
estate or retail or construction or
Finance or insurance or Computer
Services you do the same thing for a
living that I do
you're in the business of serving other
people
and if you start to look closely enough
you will find opportunities for
unreasonable Hospitality to give people
more than they could ever possibly
expect all around you
take real estate agents for example
every time I've bought or rented a new
apartment at best the agent has left me
a bottle of sparkling wine in the fridge
as my thank you slash congratulations
gift
at worst they've just thrown the keys in
the kitchen counter
now this is someone with whom I've spent
weeks if not months looking together for
my new home
if they've been paying attention they
should know every intimate detail of my
life
so imagine instead if the first time my
wife and I walked into the apartment
that we ended up choosing they overheard
her talking about the Nook she imagined
herself doing yoga every morning and
when we moved in instead of that
obligatory bottle of bubbles in that
Nook was a brand new yoga mat with a
candle and a note that said welcome to
your new home
I think that would be pretty cool
and compared to the average commission
it's a pretty insignificant investment
in what will inevitably become a
lifelong relationship
this is not rocket science
it just requires caring a little bit
more
and trying a little bit harder
being present
not taking yourself too seriously
and remembering that one size fits one
just go with me here imagine if the
person that checked you into the
dentist's office started thinking like
this imagine if the person that sold you
your next car started thinking like this
or better yet imagine if everyone on
your entire team started thinking like
this
because making good products it's no
longer enough
serving them efficiently is no longer
enough
it's how we make people feel that
matters most of all
because I believe we are on the
precipice of becoming a Hospitality
economy
listen unreasonable Hospitality helped
my restaurant accomplish every single
one of our goals and it turns the people
I worked with from a collection of
individuals into a trusting team
unlocking a collective creativity and
capacity we had never experienced before
so the next time you find yourself
pursuing a relationship
with someone you work with
or someone you serve
I'm just here to encourage you to try
being a little bit more unreasonable
give people that sense of belonging give
them a memory that can last a lifetime
it will transform your business
but I can also promise you this it will
make you
and all the people around you feel
really
really good
thank you
[Applause]